[Musique]
dans cette vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh Jésus oh ce n'est pas bon
non non non oh tu ne vas pas laisser tomber
celui-là
oh la foule oh je suis tellement désolé d'
accord je  J'ai passé beaucoup trop de temps dans
la cabine téléphonique si je suis honnête avec
moi-même, j'aurais probablement dû
appeler le 911
maintenant,
ouais, j'ai raison, vous êtes tous les deux un vrai point ici,
ah [ __ ], c'est une cabine téléphonique qui fait au
coin d'une rue disparaître dans  98
était-ce bien de me garder donne-moi ça
non c'est vrai que les autres gars le font
normalement mais tu ne serais probablement pas
mort si c'est Logan qu'il doit changer en
j'étais un [ __ ] de débardeur de l'ouragan
Paul gel du cerveau
oh ouais elle elle va  mordre la partie devrait
t'expliquer pas pour moi tu es mort en
lambeaux
[Musique]
toi